he has no staff no budget and gets no
paycheck but Nasir Ahmed fayeg still
comes to work in Afghanistan's mission
to the United Nations this was the
attorney area for our entrances was the
office of some of the colleagues
as the charged Affair he is now his
country's highest ranking official in
New York even if the de facto Taliban
government in Afghanistan doesn't
recognize him for the past 20 years
people have been suffering and
I don't want to leave my country I don't
want to leave my job I want to stay and
serve my my country and my people
under a legitimate government under a
government that is uh
that the people
that is elected based on the people as
well it is fayeg who represents his
country in official U.N meetings a
graduate of Kabul University he
describes himself as a civil servant
representing his country's professional
class the Taliban has named its own
spokesman to serve as ambassador to the
United Nations but so far the
credentials committee which consists of
nine member countries including the
United States Russia and China has
refused to consider the request after
the Taliban took control the security
Council called for an inclusive
negotiated political settlement one that
includes the participation of women with
no progress on those contentious issues
the UN has yet to recognize the de facto
government U.N Secretary General Amina
Mohammed says the taliban's desire to
have a representative at the United
Nations was made clear when she traveled
to Kabul recently hoping to convince
them to reverse bans on women work
talking and going to school I went into
Afghanistan thinking perhaps the most
conservative of them didn't care about
recognition they do
recognition is one leverage that we have
and we should hold on to it fayegg says
he hopes to return home someday the
picture is very gloomy in the future
it's uncertain but we are still hopeful
and that's why we are trying our best as
Afghans for now his job in New York
appears secure even if his country's
future isn't Kristen salumi Al Jazeera
the United Nations